une roue des labels voilà l'activité
proposée par greenpeace que ce soit la
case agriculture biologique appellation
d'origine protégée ou label rouge tous
ont des caractéristiques particulières
aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est de
sensibiliser et d'informer la population
sur ce critère parce qu'aujourd'hui il
existe un flou sur les labels un label
une garantie sur l'origine la qualité
les méthodes de production encore les
caractéristiques sociales et
environnementales d'un produit
alimentaire à l'origine de cette journée
de sensibilisation
une étude sur onze label les critères
sociaux économiques et environnementaux
à partir des cahiers des charges ont été
analysés par greenpeace
july il protège un peu l'environnement
il protège bien les travailleurs et pour
attirer les consommateurs
par contre le label rouge peur
d'annoncer un cahier des charges qui est
un peu vide on a par exemple
label rouge du port qui est assez
qui est très mal par rapport à son
époque vraiment aller économique de
temps en temps c'est un peu compliqué de
s'y retrouver parce que il ya tellement
de la belle que des fonds se dit ah quel
label prend 2 quel est le mieux pour
notre santé pour l'environnement près
c'est qu'on a un peu de mal à s'y
retrouver de temps en temps c'est que ça
s'est compliqué d'après un sondage elle
s à 2 mars 2021 80 % des français
interrogés ont déclaré chercher
régulièrement des informations sur le
lieu d'origine du produit